that's a boy Bevan I like hangry like
Snickers style like I didn't eat Cody
and Noelle are two youtubers who got
together to form the comedy rap wait
hold on are you angry screen I can't see
it oh oh my bad yeah no dude it's all
good man sorry this is no golden I see
how it is dude no this is me in Bevin
leave me in the dark yeah you and Bab
stir the beaver I yeah my initial
thought when I saw this video my first
thought was [ __ ] this guy man or like
you know even just seeing the the title
and thumbnail he didn't know what he's
[ __ ] talking about then I was like
now shut up dude we maybe we need to
think about this yeah you're right you
know that's my ego yeah okay the way we
will talk about after but I think it's
something a lot of people naturally
suffer from and I think you see more of
it just because so much stuff is on the
internet and you do have access to
random people's opinions about the show
and stuff and I think you get a majority
of everyone does get some majority of
like either random opinions or you know
opinions from people who don't really
watch what they do and so there it's
easy to just dismiss it you know oh this
person doesn't know what they're talking
about or this person doesn't understand
what I'm trying to do so I think videos
like this can easily just escape you
because you're so quick to just out kiss
my ass but yeah yeah I agree
TMG or tawny make gang and their songs
are pretty good and their podcast is
also not bad but I'll take it not bad
and then I'll take it from an Englishman
I'll take pretty good and not bad
I think he's Australian isn't he no I
couldn't help but notice I said the word
lark oh yeah yeah even better lark like
a lot and I wondered exactly how often
do that say these well I like this guy's
so you take a whole heap of morbid
curiosity work that's brutally in a
global pandemic causing me to self
quarantine so I can't go outside and
spend time with my friends that don't
exist
and what you end up with is me go mad it
I completely mess that he's Aussie
I really think it's such a fat strike
for me he's gonna be so offended
watching this he's gonna say I'm English
[ __ ] you guys yeah the fact I'm an
Englishman okay I respect it or whatever
wait ozzie oh never mind
no even better cast a release and
cutting out every single time I said the
word lark sorry how often did I say well
in episode 124 of the podcast which was
yeah like like it looks like like like
like like like like Mike's like we
should just change the podcast to this
this is very funny just 60 minutes of
like cut we cut out everything we said
what's up guys thanks for tuning in to
this week's podcast flashbacks of right
now like like okay I'm gonna use as a
like C as a 2% defense 98% of this is
super valid the only 2% I'm going to
defend are the times where we've been on
the road and our brains were a bit fried
from forming that's and where we are out
of gas that's the only 2% of the hundred
percent likes I will defend but that's
enter Bulls it for the 2% where we were
completely taxed from touring so we had
no capacity to think yep this one was
Australia yeah yeah that was recently
yeah this is Australia so we can't even
use jetlag as an excuse here yeah we
were already like in that time zone
like like like like like like like like
our new song and it's like which is like
like like like oh my good basically be
like this is so like four episodes to
like this isn't even the worst one
holy feels pretty wild but anyway the
night man what'd you say that's a
shout-out to this man everybody show Bev
and some love dude yeah man
no Isley i-i-i-i-i like I love stuff
like this because there's no way you're
ever perfect right and I'm just not
trying to harp on the same thing but I
don't know I like this whatever what
were you about to say this is one of
those things where when you hear it you
can't stop thinking about it yeah I
never noticed I listen to our podcast
all the time mm-hmm because I'm vain
mm-hmm I've never noticed it yeah but I
do notice it on other people's and it
annoys me so I'm glad that someone
brought this up because mmm it was a
kind of an eye-opening thing I was like
I'll [ __ ] do we do that of course we do
yeah it's no we're [ __ ] saying half
the time so we just you know we got it
we got to find a different word mmm like
what if we replaced it with you know
smegma for example or do we just say
that instead just a harmonized hmm yeah
yeah if it was something enjoyable maybe
it wouldn't be so bad but the word like
is such a what if you replaced it with
yes I'm watching the tiger King and oh
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's pretty good turn it into the
horniest podcast ever yeah no I was
gonna say you're not perfect and you
clearly you got to respect a guy who sat
through four episodes and put together a
tedious cut like this just to say I like
you guys but you do this too much you
can't mad at that in the slightest oh
that's very true man that's very true
this probably was so tedious yeah I can
miss edit extremely time-consuming so a
shout-out to Bev man this has 13,000
views on YouTube Wow when I saw it I had
like a hundred that's crazy
I think the good part about calling it
out like this are like acknowledging it
is it'll be in our minds at least I hope
my goal with this is to burn it into my
brain we talked about it for ten minutes
and I'll stop doing it and just even
with how much I'm streaming I think this
is a good thing to look at because I
noticed I was doing um on stream a lot
and something you can when I look back
at some of the like the vod's i can see
my brain like the dissociation happening
like i say um and then i think about
everyone who's ever told me not to say
um and i start saying it more you can't
really blame yourself for that though if
you're going for four hours yeah but god
you gotta give your yourself a little
break we need up maybe we need a like
jar or a Nam JA R ooh where every time
we say it we contribute and then at the
end we buy something at the end of the
month we buy something for the podcast a
a that's actually really cool I like
that I like that a lot actually yeah
it's kind of a good idea we should we
should we should count up however many
he counted and then figure out something
that will have Kyle do that well if Kyle
count all the spins you put together and
then figure out something cool for the
podcast
cost-wise and that'll be our first like
jar purchase yeah I like that a lot but
when we get windows like something had a
set wet when it does like count all the
time or does it not count when we use it
correctly I think yeah I think use best
judgment I think if we're using it
because we're fumbling over our words
then yeah definitely we're gonna buy
something cool then everyone's gonna go
now run that [ __ ] up run that like jar
up man don't change keep doing you be
you it's funny though no no I think that
super dope yeah anyways no this is good
you